hey david will republicans support an
election day
uh an election delay rather if
donald trump is definitely going to lose
so
this is an interesting question because
it first assumes that republicans or
trumpists
might come to the conclusion that trump
definitely is going to lose
i don't think the average trumpist is
going to believe that going into
november
in other words the average trumpist no
matter what
if trump says he's doing well in the
polls which he's been saying even though
he's not
they will believe trump has a chance so
in practice
i don't think this scenario is going to
come up because you're not going to
convince
the the vast majority of trumpists that
trump is
is going to lose let's imagine you did
would they then support an election
delay if trump wanted it
absolutely if there's one thing we've
learned during this presidency
it's that anything trump wants
his followers want if it's the
authoritarian deployment
of paramilitaries with no badges and
unmarked vans to portland and chicago
and wherever
uh even if they thought they were small
government conservative libertarians or
whatever up until they
they're supporting it no question about
it when it's
trump against vote by mail they're
against vote by mail trump comes out as
he did
last week or the week before and says in
florida
it's safe and everybody should vote by
mail they immediately fall in line and
they say yes yes everybody should be
voting by mail because donald trump said
so so
if donald trump were trump has floated
it
he's not said we need to delay but he's
floated it and he said we might not know
the results for weeks or years he even
said which is
absolutely ridiculous if trump actually
came out and said
i believe we should delay the election
to whatever date it would be crazy right
there'd be no legal basis for it
of course a huge portion of his
followers will fall in line
because they fall in line with
absolutely anything that he says
we have to make sure that we start
voting now i mean there are states where
in
i think is it two and a half weeks or
three weeks
um early voting absentee ballots start
uh we have to overwhelm the vote so that
it's not close
and we need to just remember that a
federal election has never been delayed
there have never been delays to
presidential elections
his followers are liable to support
absolutely anything that he wants
what we have to make sure we do is to
vote participate keep the pressure on as
far as the post office keep the pressure
on as far as
uh vote by mail and um none of this
stuff is really going to become an issue
and i'm
i'm not i understand why i'm getting so
many questions like
will republicans support delaying the
election or will the military be
required to remove donald trump i get it
i understand why that's going on and
it's because many of you
are willing to crawl over broken glass
to vote in november
one way or the other by mail or in
person because you see the importance of
removing donald trump i get it
i do not believe it's actually going to
come to that i do not believe we are
going to have
any serious possibility of an election
delay
i do not believe that if donald trump
loses the military will be required to
remove him i do not believe it
uh these could be famous last words i
will eat my hat
uh if it ends up working out that way in
november
into january we have a great bonus show
for you today
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinedpakman.com or a patron
at patreon.com pakman show
i will see you on the bonus show